in the last video we began to see some
pretty good evidence that dna was a
molecular basis for inheritance and we
saw that from the work of avery mccarthy
and macleod where they tried to identify
whether it was dna or proteins that
acted as the transformation principle in
griffith's experiments and i encourage
you to watch that video if all of this
sounds unfamiliar
but even their work in 1944 was not
viewed as conclusive evidence it was
viewed as strong evidence but not
conclusive evidence because remember how
they did it they took the heat killed
smooth strain the smooth strain you
might remember from griffith's
experiment was the virulent one the heat
killed it when you heat kill it in an
injected mouse it didn't do anything to
the mouse but if you took the the killed
heat if you if you took the heat killed
smooth strain and put it with the rough
strain it somehow transformed the rough
strain into the smooth strain into the
violent stain and so they took the
heat-killed smooth strain and they took
out its different components and they
eventually were able to isolate one that
was able to transform the rough strain
into the smooth strain by itself and
then they applied all sorts of chemical
tests to it and said hey there's pretty
good evidence that this is dna but it
wasn't conclusive because well maybe
they didn't purify it properly or maybe
there was still a little bit of protein
maybe it was mostly dna but maybe it was
a little bit of protein that was still
left there that actually did the
transformation so the scientific
community they weren't just saying hey
that looks pretty good let's move on
let's just assume they wanted to
continue to test it and especially test
it in different ways
and the conclusive evidence didn't come
until a few years later until
1952 when alfred hershey and martha
chase decided to study t2 bacteriophage
so let me write this down
t2 bacteriophage
this is phage that infects bacteria
bacteriobacteriophage when you hear the
word phage we're referring to viruses
now they knew that t2 bacteriophage was
composed of
of proteins and dna
and they didn't well we now know that
it's a protein shell and there's dna
inside
but they from their point of view they
said okay it's made up you know if we
look at if we try to if we look at the
stuff that viruses that this virus is
made of it's protein and dna so protein
plus dna
and they knew that this virus when when
it when it infects
bacteria it injects something into that
bacteria so it injects something
injects
something
and that something
is what what hijacks that bacteria's
genetic information to start producing
more of the t2 bacteriophage so they
could identify the something that gets
injected if they could figure out if
that something was either protein or
virus then they would have conclusively
proven that that either
sorry if they could show that that
something was not protein or virus if it
was protein or dna and they could show
that it was either protein or dna then
they could show conclusively that it's
either the protein or the dna that forms
the molecular basis and so they're
actually quite skeptical of avery
mccarty and mcleod's experiments they
actually hershey and chase actually
thought that they were going to show
that it was the protein and remember
this whole time people you know protein
we know it's these complex molecules
that have these different shapes and all
these different amino acids it seems
like that's much more likely to encode
the complexity of genetic information
than dna they didn't have they didn't
have an appreciation for the structure
of dna at this time so they devised an
experiment to figure out what is that
something that there that the the t2
bacteriophage is injecting is that
something
is that something protein is it protein
or
dna
so this is the question
so what they do is they take two batches
or they develop two batches of t2
bacteriophage
one batch of the t2 bacteriophage they
do it in the prod and they do it in the
presence of radioactive phosphorus
phosphorus 32.
in the other batch they they i guess you
could say they grow that t2
bacteriophage in the process of another
radioactive isotope but this time it is
of sulfur this is sulfur
35. so why are they doing that
well phosphorus is found in dna so in
this in this first batch the radioactive
marker you could say is going to
incorporate itself into the dna
in the second batch sulfur is found in
the protein and not in the dna and so
this would actually tag the protein
parts and if you're wondering well how
do you develop these radioactive batches
well you let the viruses hijack cells in
a medium that has either the radioactive
sulfur or the radioactive phosphorus and
as they reproduce they are going to
incorporate that radioactive material
into either the protein or the dna of
the new viruses that get produced so
anyway they were able to produce
some of the t2 bacteriophage in the
presence of the radioactive phosphorus
and they knew that way that the the dna
would get that radioactive material in
it and then with the radioactive sulfur
they said the protein would have that
radioactive sulfur and then for each of
those batches they gen they then
infected bacteriophage with them and
they said okay they're going to inject
something into the bacteriophage and to
figure out what that something is that
was injected into the bacteriophage they
take the products in either of the two
scenarios
they first blend them up so that all of
the the the stuff that's left outside
gets
gets taken off of the surface of the
bacteria cells and then they stick it
into a centrifuge and the centrifuge is
you can imagine it's kind of just a big
spinning machine if you were to take a
test tube and take it sideways one way
to think about it put it sideways like
this put maybe like a stopper in it so
nothing leaks and then you spin it
around really really really really fast
what you're going to find you can
actually generate significant g forces
and so the heavier stuff is going to
gravitate to the bottom of the test tube
or to the right the way when it's on its
side and the lighter stuff is going to
gravitate to
the left and it turns out that the
bacteria the actual bacteria cells
bacterial cells those are heavier so the
bacterial cells are going to go towards
the bottom of the test tube and they're
going to form a material that we call
the pellet and then all the other stuff
all of the fluid and the leftover uh
phage parts those are going to be those
are going to go up to the top of the
test tube and we call that the
supernatant
supernatant i always have trouble
pronouncing that supernatant and so they
said look if we look at the pellet which
they knew had the bacterial cells in
there or you could even say the remnants
of the bacterial cells if we look at if
the pellet here if the pellet contains
phosphorus that means that the dna our
radioactive dna or our tagged dna made
it into the bacteria but if it contains
sulfur that means that the protein made
it into the bacteria and what they found
is
they found
that the radioactive phosphorus
the radioactive phosphorus
was in the pellet which allowed them to
conclude that hey it's the dna from the
virus that made it inside of the
bacteria and not the protein and then
they said well it must be wow the you
know avery mccarthy and mcleod were
correct it's actually the dna that is
this transformation principle that can
go in and hijack the genetic the
machinery of the bacteria to produce
more of the actual virus so this is a
really really really really big deal
once again we started with we started
with mendel saying hey we have these
inheritable factors and they seem to to
segregate and assort in certain ways
they seem to be discrete
boverin sutton said hey chromosomes seem
to kind of their behavior during meiosis
when cell split
seemed to kind of match up to that
morgan starts to provide some evidence
we have griffith's experiments with the
with the mice and and the bacteria and
saying hey look there's some
transformation principle avery mccarty
and mcleod say hey looks like when we
try to really purify this transformation
principle it seems like dna is what
really matters and then hershey and
chase validate that even more
conclusively